well we'll move to this are the new
questions about president Trump's
relationship now with the top disease
expert dr. Anthony Fauci that member of
the task force and we see with the
president most days this is coming after
the president retweeted a post that was
critical of dr. pouchy and called for
his firing that coming shortly after the
doctor said this about whether the
United States could have acted sooner in
response of the spread of kovat 19 watch
I mean obviously you could logically say
that if you had a process that was
ongoing and you started mitigation
earlier you could have saved lives
obviously no one is going to deny that
but what goes into those kinds of
decisions is complicated if we had right
from the very beginning shut everything
down it may have been a little bit
different but there was a lot of
pushback about shutting things down back
then dr. pouchy has run the National
Institute of Allergy and Infectious
Diseases for more than three decades and
through six administrations just to give
you a little perspective on his
background Murray what is the
significance of what we watched play out
this weekend on this matter
dr. Fauci has throughout this entire
crisis been a voice of scientific reason
of scientific facts I think that's why
you've seen him get so much widespread
acclaim from both Democrats and
Republicans across the partisan spectrum
people are looking to dr. fowey to tell
the truth and that's what he did this
weekend and I think that's that's why
he's in his position that's why I'm glad
he's still in his position because
that's what scientists and doctors need
to do I have long ago given up trying to
read the tea leaves of Donald Trump's
Twitter and try and parse out from that
might what might come policy-wise but I
hate the fact that he retweeted someone
calling for doctor foul cheese firing
and if he did if President Trump did
anything to sideline doctor foul Qi to
try and move him out of such a prominent
role I hope you would hear pushback from
Democrats and Republicans because doctor
foul Qi has played such an important
role in helping the American people
understand this crisis Harris you know
there seems to be
have bipartisan agreement on what Marie
harf just said I'll take it a step
further though the the palace intrigue
and the fighting and all I just I don't
know if we have time for that
like as a nation Melissa yeah no we
absolutely don't although when you say
that you know he went out this weekend
and told the truth it the implication is
that the president is not telling the
truth and I don't think that's accurate
I think that what the president is
reacting to is this idea that he takes
his responsibility for the health and
welfare of the American people very
personally and and you know very
seriously and so I would imagine that
when he feels like someone is attacking
him potentially for not doing his very
best to safeguard America's health and
welfare that you know he he gets very
angry and that's where those tweets come
from and and he just takes it incredibly
personally I agree with Marie that I
think that dr. pouchy is somebody who
you know both sides really trust and
it's essential that he's part of the
conversation and that he continues in
his post and I think that all of us sort
of we take comfort in the fact that
these two do disagree and then move
along and dr. Pesci has said repeatedly
you know the president listens to me
even when we disagree he listens to me
and we have a conversation I hear him he
hears me and she's right that is
essential going forward you know guy I
look at this and I wrote down just a
note to myself about when I watch public
people fight and how usually is
Melissa's pointing out usually the
debate sometimes can be edifying because
you can see that one person maybe has
your point of view the other person
doesn't so on and so forth and how they
work it out and I think Melissa is
absolutely right about that it's it's
actually pretty healing to see that go
forth because at least you think it's
not about who's right but what's right
which is always my goal I do have to say
though at times the public fight is not
helpful when it's just about the sniping
where do you put this well I think with
doctor foul she in this little flap
involving the weekend
I think if you
watch the full interview that he did on
another network that got so much
attention he was actually in some ways I
think defending the president because
there were people out there and there's
a CNN doctor saying oh they should have
acted sooner they were far too late to
do what was necessary and foul she came
back and said actually it's really not
that simple for all these various
reasons I think he and the president
really again are basically on the same
page here there is a fringe of people I
think it's deeply irresponsible who want
to see doctor foul he fired I think
that's really would be a terrible idea
for the country even if you disagree
with what he's done you think we've gone
too far
to fire this man who's an eminent expert
I think would be a disastrous mistake
the thing that is also bothersome to me
Harris is the degree to which some in
the media seem very invested in this
palace intrigue plotline where they sort
of stoke every ember almost like they're
trying to goad the president into doing
something that would be very bad for the
country but could be bad for him
politically so they love expressing
concerns about how this might happen it
almost feels like a perverse rooting
interest and I wish they would knock
that off you know I kind of put it in
almost another lane to I mean you can
have that point of view that it's
political or this might even be worse is
it personal are they looking for those
moments to light up themselves in a
moment that really isn't even focused on
them I don't know it's just a question
dr. nasch watt i I want to go to you
before we go to a quick break just to
get your take on this I mean dr. pouchy
I spit out a couple lines about his
resume but as another medical expert
when you look at this what do you make
of the the going back and forth I have
so much respect for dr. pouchy his
number one priority are patients not
politics and that I actually watched his
full interview yesterday they that that
Network they twisted his words he didn't
absolutely say yes we should have done
this he said you know coulda shoulda
woulda of course in any situation if you
start from negative day a negative
experience in November it would have
been a better outcome he was
generalizing his statement but they
twisted his words I think what he's
doing is doing everything in his power
to protect American
that's what we need interesting you know
for a while about this time we had been
hitting hearing regularly from Governor
Cuomo and one thing that he has said guy
and I I heard you saying mm-hmm just a
moment ago as dr. new shot was was
talking he said you know the time for
going back and taking a look at what was
done and the blame so on and so forth is
not this time he said it in many
different ways he said there no blue
states no red states just red white and
blue a quick last thought and we'll move
on there will be lots of time for
finger-pointing and it's already here in
some ways I think that ultimately and
we'll talk about this later in the
program the results are gonna be what
matters most and a lot of the partisan
food fighting currently happening I
think is probably a big turn-off to most
people who just want their families to
get back to work but they want to be
healthy first and foremost